klaws tourismus gmbh dauert ja auch noch
ein bisschen bis weihnachten
etwas gedacht und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video ich hoffe natürlich
jedes gut ja der ein oder andere von
euch hat mich gefragt ob ich denn dieses
jahr auch wieder ein paar
adventskalender bestellung die dann
öffne dann dachte ich eigentlich nicht
aber lass uns das doch mal wieder machen
wirklich eigentlich wollte das nicht
mehr machen aber irgendwie habe ich
jetzt doch einbestellt weil ich fand ihn
ganz cool der hat mich 94 euro kostet
490 euro 95 grad habe ich gesehen der
kostet jetzt nur noch 74 euro also habe
ich quasi 20 euro in den wind geschossen
super ich muss aber sagen das teil hat
ein überraschungs wert von 300 euro das
heißt ich habe meine 490 euro bezahlt
und 300 euro an werkzeug drin sein mehr
als das dreifache das ist doch mal eine
ansage und deswegen habe ich das ding
bestellt leider ist der kalender noch
nicht hier wir müssen jetzt erstmal bei
der post abholen da ich nicht hier war
und er hat mich in meinem briefkasten
passt kein nachbar balladen vielen dank
für nichts
[Musik]
das erste event kalender ist da müsste
ja ganz vergessen heute ich hab in
meinem koffer haben auch die ganzen
neuen erblasser scheiße ich erst mal
runter du bist jetzt unwichtig man misst
hier bei den erfolg der shockwave er den
15 einfach geile teilen das problem ist
an meinem kofferraum der ist ein
bisschen klein ich wollte ihn mit in
meinem büro nehmen weil die alle noch
verlost werden ihr könnt einen coolen
kommentar schreiben warum wir ein von
den baslern haben wollte und dann
schicke ich euch die zu oder wenn hier
aus kann er kommt vielleicht komme ich
sogar persönlich vorbei geht ist es ja
bestimmt mittlerweile ich war dieses
jahr teil der nbbl 2021 und die läuft
gerade noch geht in die endphase jetzt
ist natürlich die frage wo kriegt in den
kalender reihe naja bevor wir jetzt
auspacken check erstmal ab was bei der
nbbl so abgeht und schaut euch dann auf
jeden fall die videos auf dem surfboard
kanal an jetzt wird hier genick mct
knick knack und
die verfolgungsjagd geht los hier mit
team wie die wollen natürlich team
bieber fans so richtig auf die pelle
rückt aber dazu müssten sie erst mal was
mir leid hier schlagen die vorgelegt
haben mit 25 büchern und hier gehen alle
zu boden an der ersten station zur
selbst viele städte oder sitzen dann
bist du jetzt halt mein beifahrer hier
und ihr könnt noch eine weile darin
bleiben kursiert aus dem schaufenster so
heute herzlich willkommen zurück ich
kann mich gar nicht mehr so genau daran
erinnern war nicht den letzten fenster
aufgemacht haben wahrscheinlich nicht
letztes jahr im sommer ach so das ist
vielleicht auch noch wichtig zu sagen
das ist ein männer adventskalendern mit
lifestyle-produkten youtube produkten
und so weiter und so fort für den mann
und ich war halt einfach mal ein
bisschen neugierig auf das abzocke ist
oder ob es wirklich so ist
liegt würde ich mal sagen so ungefähr
fünf kilo und hier haben wir auch schon
den dreifachen wert wenn ich würde sagen
ja wir machen es halt wie immer ich
werde ein kletter nach dem anderen
öffnen und die produkte euch zeigen
weshalb ihr könnt mir super gerne auch
adventskalender schicken wenn wir meint
so er alex essen bestellen müssen schon
teurer sein sonst uns das nicht wenn ich
also nicht so welche für 10 euro mit
bisschen schokolade drin dann starten
wir doch mal rein mit kläppchen nummer
eins was haben wir hier ja das ist hier
schon mal statt
eine schlafmaske ach so ja das kann man
sich auf die haut auftragen und ich habe
so was noch nie verwendet aber
irgendwann ist ja immer mal das erste
mal ich werde die frei sind von diesen
einzelnen sachen euch jetzt noch nicht
die einbilden wir werden erstmal
auspacken eins nach dem anderen und dann
werde ich am ende alles noch ein
bisschen recherchieren dann zu schauen
ob das wirklich so viel wert hat weil
das kann ich mir eigentlich nicht
vorstellen aber wer weiß so bachmann
weiter mit der nummer zwei die ist schon
ein bisschen schwerer haben wir hier ja
super sofortreparatur war sie nur skin
expert auch irgendwie wieder was für die
haut
da kann man ja eigentlich direkt mattes
oder das riecht aber nicht so gut
[Musik]
jetzt glänzt sich wahrscheinlich nicht
sofort die linderung für sehr trockene
gespannte oder jupiter hat schon ab der
ersten anwendung dann lasse ich das
jetzt einfach mal während des videos ein
geht nun weiter mit der 3 muss jetzt ein
bisschen aufpassen dass er sich alles
ineinander zusammenfällt aber das hat
wahrscheinlich auch ein system jetzt
vielleicht mal irgendwas was ich mir
nicht aha das ist das denn alkohol was
haben wir hier bot
das finde ich für mich persönlich schon
ganz cool also ich bin jetzt nicht so
ist der dschinn fällen aber hier haben
wir drei sind 45 prozent tranken
abwehrverhalten ein kleines fläschchen
aber immerhin weiter geht's das ist ein
bisschen leichter hd für den man
natürlich wieder etwas koste was ein
euro wenn überhaupt es hat keine große
flasche weiter geht's mit erfüllt
tetris spielen geil das ist ganz gut den
kenn ich tabaks den gibt's eigentlich in
jedem guten friseurladen und zwar denke
ich auch dass der seinen wert hat
american crew form in krien weil er
riecht gut super also ich muss sagen
wir's jetzt bin ich schon positiv
überrascht ich hätte es wirklich nicht
gedacht dass da so was drin ist also
ehrlich nicht weiter geht's mit der
nummer 6 und das ist nikolaus also hier
ist jetzt bestimmt der banker drin
david safetypay
rasierer ich habe zwar eigentlich ein
elektrischen rasierer aber man weiß ja
nie wofür man immer gebrauchen kann und
was mir direkt auf hält der ist schon
sehr hochwertig ne guck mal hier
hat ist waren rasierer der wird bestimmt
seinen werten aber vorsichtig weiter
geht es mit der nummer sie dann haben
wir hier auf die nummer 8 und die nummer
9 nicht zusammenkommen bitte bleibt
immer das ist wirklich mit system das
muss man sagen nichts fällt auseinander
die nummer 7 ok nummer sieben ist ein
bisschen leichter schaden
das ist halt nur irgendwie so eine
parfüm probe wird auch nicht viel kosten
schätzt sich mal euro wobei der fankurve
ist ja eigentlich gratis dann haben wir
hier in yach lag kathrin war befreit die
haut von mitessern das problem ist halt
bei mir ich selbst wenn ich mal in
peking haben oder so ich mache da nie
irgendwie so ein zeug drauf damit habe
ich noch nie angefangen und eigentlich
habe ich in lehrer zusehends auch nicht
vor damit irgendwann mal anzufangen
vielleicht fange ich jetzt deswegen mal
damit an und testet das aber inhaltlich
davon auch nicht so viel aber gut danke
für diesen blackhat rheinufer und dann
haben wir hier noch für nummer 9 was ist
deutsch oder pocket double chocolate ich
würde mal behaupten dass es irgendwie so
ein protein snack wir probieren in
direktwahl und noch 25 prozent
gutscheincode drauf danke auf jeden fall
aber dann werde ich denke nicht benutzen
es sei denn ich denke ich mir jetzt
super
tragisch definitiv von fitness drinks
stimmig weil deutlich später noch essen
aber jetzt nicht unbedingt jetzt so
langsam müssen aber mal wieder gute
sachen kommen weil hier haben wir von
den neuen sachen 34 sachen dabei die
station und euro kosten die jetzt dieses
ding hier auch zum beispiel und das
stand ja irgendwas von 300 euro die
nummer 10 sport gehen brennend für den
erfolg dank dafür und dann haben wir
hier noch die nummer elf das danach so
okay so nagl clipper wenn man irgendwie
sich die füße schneidet oder sonst was
also die fußnägel brauche ich ja glaube
ich an sich nicht viel zu erklären
sondern sonne viewty damen hier exakt
einer stunde kann ich mir auch
vorstellen dass das durchaus fünf euro
kostet vielleicht auch mehr keine ahnung
dann haben wir hier oben direkt die
zwölf und 13 jahren wieder irgend eine
handcreme handcreme ok damit die händler
gut riechen und hier haben wir das
nächste von dm alverde er so langsam
also leute ohne spaß wir haben jetzt
mehr als die hälfte ausgepackt und das
sind safe nicht 100 euro warenwert den
wir haben safe also ich würde sagen
maximal 70 wenn überhaupt es sei denn
dieser gillette rasierer kostet 50 euro
aber das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen
wir machen weiter mit der friert sind
wir machen weiter mit der 15 dann haben
wir noch die 16 okay jetzt aber mal hier
und klar der kalender kostet jetzt nur
noch 74 euro oder so ich habe aber 94
bezahlt das hier sind kaugummi und wie
kann ich gebrauchen war luca wo nicht
ganz mit vitamin c das sind doch keine
kaugummis naja was ist das denn also
wenn ihr die jetzt riechen könnte liegt
sehr sehr intensiv manuka honig gab es
da sind also bonbons mit extrem viel
vitamin c drin war hinzu kommen die dann
schmeckt ein bisschen komisch aber kann
man auf jeden fall essen wenn man sich
dann damit besser fühlt aufgrund des
ganzen vitamin-c-gehalt super in der 15
ist ein wir haben wir die nächste maske
die hydro power maske ich gehe ja auch
mal davon aus sie sind kalender gibt es
wahrscheinlich auch für lady ist dann
nur mit frauen produkten lacoste auch
wieder nix also ja und hier haben wir s
oliver black label papa das ist ja
vielleicht dann doch ein bisschen was
wert aber hallo einmal testmittel
das riecht aber nicht schlecht es
olivenöl ja okay so was genau ich musste
kurz wieder in meinem kopf das
zusammentreffen mit axa und aegon aktien
graf und axor konflikts für den flex
gucke ich mir gleich noch mal genauer an
was hat denn hier kostet weiter geht's
wir haben jetzt noch diese sam dann
haben wir noch die 18 die 19 die 19
staaten mit der sukzessiven pflaster
kann man immer mal gebrauchen für einen
adventskalender würde ich mich jetzt
wahrscheinlich morgens nicht so drüber
freuen weil die meisten leute wenn die
auch schon machen ihnen kläppchen auf
kennt man ja durfte ich früher auch mal
von der schule kläppchen auch schokolade
rein aufs fahrrad und ab zur schule und
wenn man dann morgens blasenpflaster
bekommt ja dann ist der tag eigentlich
schon gelaufen es sei denn man hat sich
am tag davor ne miese blase abends
gelaufen und hat keine blase platzt
lange zu hause dann sieht das ganze
natürlich schon wieder ganz anders aus
ok weiter mit der 18 hier haben wir den
nächsten alkohol dann wieder 13 okay
finde ich ganz gut das haben sie
wahrscheinlich auch folge mund gemacht
wir sind hier schon bei kläppchen 18
haben jetzt vielleicht so gerade hier
die 90 euro erreicht und den
versprochenen 300 dann kann man sich das
ganze vielleicht ein bisschen schöner
trinken und jetzt haben wir hier die 19
die 19 ist mies fed melitta cappuccino
cool kaffee kapseln oder kaffeepulver
proteinen kaffeepulver also nein okay es
ist kein kaffeepulver man kann das ganze
einfach eine tasse kippen dann macht ein
bisschen heißes wasser drauf und hast du
ein protein cappuccino würde ich mal
ausprobieren möchte ich mal gucken ob
das okay wir schon relativ spät
eigentlich kann ich das nicht mehr
machen kann ich nicht schlafen
dann machen wir hier weiter mit der
nummer 20 lenken doch nicht zeigen ein
bisschen aus wie das label o creme
hoppen straffende gesichtspflege also
wenn du dir den kalender gekauft hast
dann brauchst du dir die nächsten zehn
jahre auf jeden fall keine sorgen um
irgendwelche pickel im gesicht machen
oder irgendwelche falten weiter geht es
mit der 21 ich schlafe ich auch eine
originale feuchtigkeitscreme ja so tat
es hat wir erst dreimal dann haben wir
hier noch die 22 da ist bestimmt auch
der thüringische watch in der 23 jetzt
der nächste ding drin bauten brown
london ehrensperger
entschuldigung okay es ist kein ding
nicht zu verwechseln mit gin es ist
nämlich duschgel also quasi so duschgel
wie es in hotels steht und dann hier zu
guter letzt die nummer 24 okay jetzt
bitte einmal ein bisschen dramatische
musik weil ich bin mir sicher dieses
produkt kostet mindestens 200 euro weil
sonst kommen wir safe nicht auf die
versprochenen 300 euro was ich ein
bisschen schade fände aber mir
eigentlich für ein klarer weil irgendwie
müssen ja auch geld verdient naja ist ja
trotzdem irgendwo abzocke aber ich weiß
nicht hier haben wir jetzt von
baldessarini
jetzt bin ich bestimmt wieder ärger weil
ich die marke nicht kenne baldessarini
cool for sport hoffe aber das wirkt auf
jeden fall ein bisschen hochwertiger
danke dafür also ich glaub ihr werk ich
bin nicht so ganz begeistert ich werde
das jetzt mal durchrechnen ich bin
wirklich gespannt ich glaube das sind
maximal 120 euro wenn überhaupt und die
meisten sachen davon sind ja auch noch
so kleine döschen ihre probeflächen oder
sonstwas naja bis sofort leute ich hab
es mir fast gedacht also dass ich weiß
es ist halt dumm dass da 300 euro steht
ich meine ist ja klar dass die auch
irgendwas dran verdienen müssten aber
dann schreibt dass da nicht hin wenn das
nicht mal ein drittel davon ist fasst
kurz zur erklärung dieses parfüm von 24
kostet 25 euro oder anderen kostet 20
euro das sind die teuersten sachen dann
hatten wir hier noch ein rasierer der
kostet 1800 war es eigentlich und
vielleicht der eine andere wachsen auf
fünf bis zehn euro kostet aber die
meisten sachen diese kleinen döschen die
christin zwanziger packs für 30 euro
oder so diese anhebung kostet so also
täglich mehr als eur habe alles mal so
ungefähr hochgerechnet und wir landen
bei 420 euro und nicht 300 na gut was
willst du machen so ist das ich hoffe es
hat euch trotzdem gefallen schickt mir
gern noch weiter kalender abonniert den
kanal hast du nach oben da und ja das
war haut rein